como se los prometí en el vídeo anterior
resolveremos algunos ejemplos sencillos
de la ley de snl y para eso voy a usar
esta tabla con índices de refracción de
algunos de los materiales que vamos a
estar usando en estos ejemplos digamos
que aquí voy a tener aire
uno de los medios donde va a viajar la
luz
aquí en medio tengo una superficie que
es de agua
yo sé que tengo un rayo de luz que va a
caer o va a venir del aire y va a entrar
en el agua con un ángulo con respecto a
esta perpendicular
va a caer con un ángulo
de 35 grados y lo que yo quiero saber es
cuál va a ser el ángulo de refracción es
decir cuando entra el rayo de luz al
agua va a cambiar su dirección y lo que
yo quiero saber es este nuevo ángulo con
respecto a la perpendicular cuál va a
ser
quiero saber cuál es este ángulo
aquí vamos a aplicar directamente la ley
de snail y aquí voy a usar la versión
que usa los índices de refracción aquí
como les comentaba tenemos una tabla
donde están los índices de refracción
que corresponden a diversos materiales
no dice la de aires en el que el índice
de refracción del primer material que es
el aire en el aire
multiplicado por el seno del ángulo de
incidencia que en este caso es de 35
grados
va a ser igual al índice de refracción
del agua
por el seno del ángulo de refracción que
es
nuestra variable a encontrar
ya conocemos cuáles son los valores de
los índices de refracción del aire y
podemos calcular el seno de 35 grados y
de esta manera despejar el ángulo que
nos interesa vamos a sustituir esto el
índice de refracción del aire es 1.000
29 x
el seno de 35 grados menos de 35 grados
es igual al indicio de reflexión del
agua 1.33
el seno del ángulo de refracción
dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación
entre un 1.33 dividimos esto
/ 1.33
/ 1.33 estos dos se cancelan y para
encontrar esto sacamos nuestra
calculadora y asegurándonos de que se
encuentre en grados al momento de sacar
esto del seno de 35 grados tenemos 1.000
29 entre 1.33 nos queda punto 75
nos queda 0.75 aproximadamente por el
seno de
35 grados va a ser igual al seno
y este ángulo que nos interesa vamos a
calcular cuál es esto esta cantidad por
él
seno de 35 grados así que multiplicamos
esto por
35 grados el seno
y nos queda que esto es igual a punto 43
redondearlo a punto 43 14
entonces es punto
43 14 es igual al seno
y este ángulo
para encontrar este ángulo tengo que
aplicar el seno inverso en ambos lados
de la ecuación por lo que nos queda el
seno inverso
0.43 14 es igual al seno inverso de seno
se cancelan ambos y nos queda
simplemente el ángulo de interés si algo
de esto les es confuso los invito a que
revisen los vídeos de trigonometría
bueno vamos a obtener el seno inverso de
este valor volvemos a sacar la
calculadora y ahora vamos a aplicar el
sen inverso asegurándonos de tener esto
en grados y nos queda 25 puntos 55
grados que podemos redondear a 25 puntos
6 grados entonces este ángulo
de todos el ángulo de refracción es
aproximadamente igual a 25.6 grados
bueno ahora vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
vamos a hacer un poco de espacio para
que nos quepa este nuevo ejemplo digamos
que tengo una superficie por acá que es
de un material desconocido
y se encuentran junto al vacío podemos
imaginar que estamos en la estación
espacial internacional así que aquí
afuera va a haber vacío y podemos
imaginar un rayo de luz que va a llegar
aquí
y que va a entrar con cierto ángulo
pensándolo bien saben que mejor en lugar
de tener un rayo de luz que venga del
medio más rápido al medio más lento
vamos a hacer que este rayo de luz salga
del medio más lento hacia el más rápido
entonces tendríamos aquí
un rayo de luz
que sale más o menos hacia acá de este
medio más lento que no sabemos de qué
está hecho a este vacío y si recordamos
nuestra analogía del auto ya que esto
debido a esta inclinación en los
elementos del lado izquierdo de la luz
van a llegar antes al vacío o el medio
más rápido que los que están del lado
derecho entonces este rayo de luz va a
inclinarse hacia acá por lo que va a
tener un cambio de dirección así
este medio recordemos que es un material
desconocido no sabemos de qué está hecho
esto pero imaginemos que si sabemos
cuáles son estos ángulos el ángulo de
incidencia y el ángulo de refracción
aquí permítanme dibujar la vertical a
este plano
y yo sé que el ángulo de incidencia este
de acá es de 30 grados
y también sé que el ángulo de reflexión
este ángulo de aquí arriba
va a ser de unos 40 grados
dado que pudimos venir el ángulo de
incidencia y el ángulo de refracción
podremos calcular el índice de
refracción de este material desconocido
o aún mejor podemos encontrar la
velocidad de la luz en este material
pues sí si vamos a poder y lo primero es
encontrar el índice de refracción de
este material
el índice de refracción del material
desconocido y aquí vamos a aplicar la
ley de snl que nos dice que el índice de
refracción de el primer material
multiplicado por el seno del ángulo en
este caso es el ángulo de 30 grados
es igual al índice de refracción del
segundo material que en este caso es el
vacío vacío multiplicado por el seno del
ángulo de refracción que en este caso lo
especificamos de 40 grados
y de la tabla anterior vimos que el
índice de refracción del vacío es 1
recordamos la definición del índice de
refracción que es igual a la velocidad
de la luz en el vacío entre la velocidad
de la luz en el material al que queremos
sacar el índice pero aquí es el vacío
así que vuelve a hacer esta se bueno que
esto se cancela y queda que es igual a 1
podemos sustituir este 11 por el seno de
40 grados es igual a nuestro índice de
refracción desconocido por el seno de 30
grados
ahora que nos queda hacer aquí me
interesa dejar esta variable despejada
por la que voy a dividir ambos lados de
la ecuación entre seno de 30 grados
dividido esto entre seno de 30
seno de 30 grados y eso también lo
divido entre seno
30 grados me queda la n desconocida
igual a
el seno de 40 grados
entre el seno de 30 grados nuevamente
sacamos nuestra confiable calculadora y
hacemos esta operación que es el seno
de 40 grados 40 grados seno
/
seno de 30 grados
y esto es igual a 1.28 5 vamos a
redondear lo a 1.29 por lo que este
índice de refracción es aproximadamente
igual a 1.29 y aquí está encontramos el
índice de refracción para este material
que no conocemos
y recuerden que este índice si queremos
encontrar ahora la velocidad en la que
se mueve la luz en este medio pues vamos
a tomar este valor que como hemos de
encontrar y ya les había comentado que
la definición del índice de refracción
es la velocidad de la luz entre la
velocidad del medio en este caso de
nuestro medio desconocido
vamos a encontrar este valor este valor
lo conocemos y podemos despejar entonces
esta velocidad
bueno vamos a sustituir esta n es la que
acabamos de encontrar 1.29 que es igual
a la velocidad de la luz en el vacío
esta es aproximadamente igual a 300.000
kilómetros por segundo o 300 millones de
metros por segundo entre la velocidad de
este material que es el que nos interesa
encontrar para despejar este valor vamos
a multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por esta velocidad velocidad x 1.29 es
igual a esa velocidad de entre esta
misma se va a cancelar por lo que nos
queda que va a ser igual a 300 millones
de metros sobre segundo y ahora voy a
dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre
1.29 esto entre 1.29 lo mismo hago de
este lado
estos dos se cancelan y me va a quedar
que mi velocidad incógnita es igual a
trescientos millones
de metros sobre segundo / 1.29 vamos a
hacer esta operación nuevamente nuestra
confiable calculadora 300 millones
/ 1.29 es igual a
232 millones 558 mil 139 vamos a
redondear esto aproximadamente a 232
millones entonces de la velocidad que
traía o que podría tener la luz en el
vacío en este medio va a una velocidad
de tortuga
aproximadamente igual a 232 millones
de metros sobre segundo
si tuviéramos que adivinar cuál es este
material desconocido que yo acabo de
inventar podemos checar en la tabla
anterior y ver cuál se acerca a el valor
del índice de 1.29 y el que se acerca es
el agua es 1.33 de estos es el que más
se acerca así que este material
desconocido podría ser algo similar al
agua aunque ya sabemos que el agua y el
vacío no pueden estar en contacto por
cuestiones de presión esos fueron los
ejemplos bastante directos de la
aplicación de la ley de snl y en el
siguiente vídeo haremos ejemplos un
poquito más complejos